ha the ice to the right
328 the nose to the left 301 not a good
start order the eyes to the right 328
the nose to the left 301 to the eyes of
it the eyes have it a lot they defeat
them for the government only the second
appearance of Boris Johnson in the House
of Commons let's listen to him
[Applause]
about the consequences of this vote
tonight it means that Parliament is on
the brink of wrecking any deal that we
might be able to destroy
and control of the negotiations to the
EU and that would mean more differ more
delay and more confusion you themselves
would be able to decide how long to keep
this country in the ear and since I
refuse to go along with that plan we are
going to have to make a choice Mr
Speaker I don't want an election the
public election but if the house States
for this bill tomorrow the public will
have to choose who goes to Brussels on
October the 17th the sort is sounds and
take this country forward
everybody knows that if the right
honourable gentleman is the Prime
Minister he will go to Brussels and beg
for an extension
[Applause]
rustles the bonds and we will have years
more arguments over brexit and by
contrast mr. think everyone knows that
if this government is in charge and we
can try go to Brussels I will go for a
deal and I believe I will get a deal
[Applause]
don't you believe anyway on October the
31st the people of this country will
have to choose Mr Speaker the leader of
the opposition has been begging for an
election for two years he had crowds of
supporters outside calling for natural I
don't want an election but if MPs vote
tomorrow to stop negotiations and to
compel another pointless delay to brexit
potentially for years though that would
be the only way to resolve this and I
can confirm that we are tonight tabling
a motion under the fixed term Parliament
[Applause]
Tomiko hey mr. speaker on a point of
order I welcome tonight's vote we live
in a parliamentary democracy we do not
have a presidency but a prime minister
Prime Minister's govern with the consent
of the House of Commons representing the
people in whom the sovereignty rests
there is no consent there is no consent
in this house to leave the European
Union without a deal there is no
majority for no deal in the country as
I've said before if the Prime Minister
has the confidence in his brexit policy
when he has won he can put forward he
should put it before the people in a
public vote
[Applause]
he wants the table emotion for a general
election fine gets the bill through
[Applause]
in order to take no deal off the table
[Applause]